this program features live coverage of
an African safari and may include animal
kills and carcasses viewer discretion is
advised well good afternoon everybody
and welcome aboard once again for
another sunset Safari
we're coming to you live from the
Torchwood concession in the greater
Kruger National Park of South Africa my
name is Ralf kirsten and on the camera
I've got Davi today as my wingman
helping me to navigate this area which
is totally new for me so I'm very
excited I'm going to be heading on into
new landscapes and I can't wait now this
afternoon we've also got Tyler out on
foot also very exciting and James will
be heading out with the vehicle as well
we're sitting at around about 26 degrees
Celsius sort of around at 75 degrees
Fahrenheit so it's a lovely warm
afternoon and I'm hoping that it can
catch up with some lions but we will
look for everything we can and it will
be very exciting so that is what the
plan is for this afternoon please don't
forget to send us your questions and
your comments on the hashtag Safari lava
on Twitter and on the YouTube live chat
and get involved in the largest game
Drive in the world now this is all just
so new to me I've just crossed the
boundary out of Jummah so I am totally
stucked and I am ready to rumble I hope
you all are too and please send us all
your requests of what you would like us
to be finding today because I think
we're gonna get lucky so let's start up
and it's head on down the road and we'll
head towards first rocks which is where
there has been some lions they like to
hang out in that area and while we drive
on down the road
I hear that Tyler has found something
that likes to fly around
funny you know we're just admiring the
sound of a virtual Starling as it flew
on by and then our eastern scarlet
butterfly flew away my name is Taylor
mccurdy and on camera with me as as I
said earlier is Berg and well we've been
having no luck since this morning on
Safari so I'm really looking forward to
the Bush Walker's afternoon Hobie of
course is down the way just being shaded
by a tree at the moment as he waits for
us to move on from my butterfly which we
will do now because it just disappeared
I have to tell you if you didn't watch
the sunrise Safari my day started off
like that where everything I try to put
on camera to just magically vanish birds
animals it was terrible
anyway so we're gonna try and not have
an afternoon like that because it'll
watch out for the bird literally watch
out for the bird Hey sometimes as
hornbills dive down so low end up
ducking I know they do that in camp when
they go from tree to tree and then they
bang the disco ball that's hanging from
a bush willow tree right anyways let's
go and see some wildlife and James he's
got a could you we've got so much
wildlife over here sunday wildlife yeah
hold heard who drools so many of them
there's one we probably got four yeah I
decided that I am going to see here in
these holes of REE and toreano's not
going to sing house for everybody
hello I hope you're having a lovely
afternoon where have you happen to be in
the world my name is James Henry on
camera today we have got Craig vomit
that was his very speedy thumb going
past the front of the lens not fly he's
talked to us using the X bar laughs and
of course the chest him on YouTube that
is all the housekeeping I have to do
today I don't need to tell you where the
lose are because you are in your own
homes and therefore I don't need to tell
you that sort of thing all not stand up
on the back of the vehicle because you
can stand up as many times as you like
look at this could you running across
the round is actually a huge herd of
about I mean a huge herd of kudu which
is not necessarily a huge herd per se
they're about ten of them here let me
just go forward a little bit some of
them the other side of the river some of
them this side River Road I meant
there we go they are very secretive
normally and they also they tend to
panic quite easily which means that
seldom will they stand still for very
long this guy thinks we can't see him
you see oh she thinks we can't see her
I've decided that my favourite feature
of the kudu is that sort of white
clown's lipstick that they wear and
there's another one over here great
Oh are they running there we go hello
incoming little baby I'm just very nice
it was a world-class kudu starting out
so let's continue my plan this afternoon
is to head down towards sort of
treehouse waterhole Telepan and those
two water holes are in this south
western central areas of Jummah and then
maybe we'll pop down to a little bit
later the reason for that is there was
there were tracks of female leopards
going down here some from some time
yesterday evening we didn't find them -
all right at the end of the bush walk so
we're not really sure where they went
particularly fresh but we're gonna head
down that way and see if we don't cover
somewhere that wasn't covered in the
vehicle this afternoon and maybe the
Lepidus has decided to come and have
something to drink
at one of the pans that would be very
nice we think possibly shadaloo 4 year
old new friend
but we aren't sure we don't really know
this road which is called Philemon zip
is now kind of a boundary I guess
between shadows not shadows and should
you lose territory and tandi's territory
shadows territory is now in the ether we
think
there's the bird Craig its shouting it
is a crystal Bobbitt it's on the bottom
right hand side that rather dead looking
mob form tree that's the one you know
they're two of them shouting at each
other they keep calling throughout the
winter you know they're not migrants
obviously because they're still here but
many birds will go silent in the winter
months and these chaps seem to keep
going and I remember this from when I
lived in Johannesburg and there were one
of the few bird species that came to the
garden were actually quite a few bird
species but they were one of the more
colorful ones and you'd hear their call
throughout the winter often if you put
out a piece of pawpaw or something in
the morning
that's a pepino to the rest of the world
then they'd come and fight over it shot
at each other that kind of startled and
irritated look that remains on their
faces all the time so I'm running out of
steam for his calling funny I know the
colors aren't great on this but to get a
picture through no one's fault
but there are some lovely yellows and
oranges and reds and blacks and whites
formed by melanin zand keratins dr.
keratins why do I always say keratins
carotenoids is what I mean those are the
pigments that make the yellows reds and
oranges
really nice let us turn right here long
filaments cut line road down towards
treehouse waterhole malice
now the next thing that Taylor's going
to show you will hopefully not fly away
like the first thing the tailor to
achieve
is a tree and this young lid would is
not going anywhere well not anytime soon
I suppose of an elephant came around and
maybe tried to feed on it although you
don't actually ever see elephants eating
Midwood leaves they taste like I don't
think oh sorry a lot of strong as I
thought it was gonna be sorry thick not
very nice tone hmm just tastes very
leafy like standard leaf anyway so it's
not very nice but I always find it
unusual when I see laid wood trees and
especially when they're so small like
this because it often tricks me when you
look at the bark of this lid would you
think to yourself but that doesn't look
anything like the big ones that grow
along the drainage lines and the rivers
look how smooth it is whereas on the big
trees when they stand taller than 10
meters that also layer of bark it's
quite hard hard and mmm forms these
amazing ridges and that's a lovely would
just sort of look at that's also a
lovely wood to burn but good luck trying
to cut it down being so tough now huh
Ferg and I are really feeling defeated
today because well the butterflies and
and then sector of course warmed up and
like they were here this morning and and
have been flying around which is I think
what's happened with our eastern scarlet
that we had earlier and I'm sad I didn't
bring a butterfly book with me because
there's so many of them around today
which is really nice we'll try and put a
couple on when we can and if they sit
still for long enough there's something
else I just noticed down on the ground
and it's these yellow fruits that caught
my attention now looking at that I'm
thinking where did that come from
immediately I looked up to see if it was
from above but it isn't I mean that's
got to be careful when I move this one
because the plant that I actually ended
up just moving is what produced these
fruits now Kirstie says they look little
apricots well that's what they look like
when they're ripe and then have a look
come look what they look like when
they're not right Ryan get down there
yeah
angle it nicely with the Sun probably be
different this looks like a little
watermelon Hey okay so just exclaimed a
baby watermelon so these are not edible
to you and are this is the poison apple
the hoof Apple
and you'd be careful because it doesn't
little thorns along here they'd like to
grab you if instead let me show you the
ones over there you see that tiny little
thought so you actually don't even see
it but it's very prickly very very sharp
there you got to be very careful of them
it looks like something was eating the
fruit maybe an insect of sorts maybe a
bird pecked at it remember animals
digestive system are completely
different and how's that cursed not the
seed of an apricot but the seed of
tomato well it looks like tomato seeds
very cool and mystery food hey this
could confuse someone but very cool to
see
anyways that doesn't look like much of
the seeds have been fate feasted upon I
don't know how much fallacious fruit
really has to it I'm gonna open another
one have a look it doesn't look like
it's got much at all but I'm sure it'll
be the birds or something that'll be
dispersing that feeling back in my foot
pins and needles that's always a fun one
all right well I'm not gonna keep you
for much longer because I'm gonna send
you to Ralph's now who is bumbling about
I'm tortured and bumbling we are indeed
I'm still just discovering the place and
my first impression is is that there's
quite a few nice open areas a little bit
of grassland like Davi can maybe just
swing across here and just give you an
idea and nice open grass with quite a
few sort of cluster leaves thickets and
then we've got these general drainage
lines as well and I'm just moving
through just going everywhere having a
look for now obviously it's still very
similar in terms of the kind of
vegetation and the kind of vegetation
but as I said it's nice open areas and
we've just compost first Rock and I will
go back there a little bit later just to
show you if you haven't seen it nice
open area almost similar to that of the
black rocks in the Maasai Mara crowded
similar kind of scene there and of great
potential for for elephants and lions
when they're on top of those rocks now
Aaron you can find some jackals in open
areas like this and like I said I think
it was yesterday that actually I spotted
a jackal in the dark I haven't seen many
jackals in this area of the kruger park
at all so I'm gonna keep my eyes open
stop just you so we'll have a look for
that and yes it is perfect kind of
terrain for them but I'm not quite sure
why this is not why there's so few of
them here as well as the these servants
because you know the tracks that are
found in in areas just nearby to this
particular part of the Kruger has lot of
civets
and they're probably the most common
track along with jackals and yet in this
particular area they few and far between
so it's quite interesting tonight and I
wonder why it might be because of the
the number of leopards you know maybe
maybe that's big that's a good reason as
to why this a few of Civitan jackal
le I'm not holding my breath to spot any
ostriches obviously there is potential
there could be the odd one but you know
this part of the Kouga it's not the the
most ideal habitat for ostriches
although the awesome ostriches being a
very desert adapted animal they do occur
here but not in in great numbers so
we've got the odd chance that we might
spot one as well but remember we are
bordering on Juma so we can expect to
find very similar animals here as well
slightly different terrain obviously we
were in a different part of of this area
but it's it's still leading into Juma
and it's and it's pretty much the same
in terms of the animals that we should
find but you never know and I'm just
gonna keep on looking around and see
what fancy things that are hiding here
in the bushes they're very exciting I
love going into new areas getting lost
I've got my map with me just trying to
find my way around but for now I'm just
going on whatever way I feel I've
decided to Darvey when we get to a ride
we say which way right or left and so as
I continue trying to find my way around
Torchwood let's head you back to James
you know I think he's trying to find his
way around Juma he's after three and a
half years I'm at least three years I am
able to find my way around Juma
thankfully sort of there is a Franklin
crested variety as far as I'm aware and
apparently it is my third anniversary
here not today as Judy H pointed out on
Twitter my anniversary is on the 23rd
and last year I owned the fact that none
of you wished me a happy anniversary on
the 20th and Judy H pointed out of
course that I was being ridiculous
because my what I was being ridiculous
anyway but my anniversaries only on the
23rd of May
so that gives you all enough time to get
a nice card in the post for me perhaps a
small bottle of apple juice something of
that nature so that I might celebrate my
anniversary and a new hat by the way the
new hat and it is there is I told you
there was one has arrived it is in hot
sprite it is at Steph's house and with
any luck I'll have it before the end of
the week along with a new shirt this one
is getting a little bit old Kirsten says
I'll have to do a fashion show I'm
afraid there's nothing about my wardrobe
that could be described as fashion much
as I like to think of it as fashion I
must be honest with myself
no cursing I can't wear my stripy shorts
they're in Kenton where they belong
they're our holiday shorts I had bought
some stripy shorts everyone and I tried
to wear them on Safari one day and I was
told in no uncertain terms by both
Kirsten and Rebecca that they were not
going to fly
my blue shorts have also been rejected
by all except some of you quite like the
man or so were you and I are in
agreement at least there wasn't anything
in tree arts waterhole except to
terrapins which took fright and climbed
into the water and swam away so we've
continued from there we'll pop around to
the little pans down here this morning
of course hooker moody was coming out
towards the boundary from Arethusa so it
might just be worth checking our eastern
boundary to find the western boundary
sorry to find if his tracks haven't come
across well we're not going to spend a
huge amount of time trying to track him
because tracking a leopard image of the
day is really very difficult to deliver
the best of times
and as odd weather persists when there's
quite heavy sort of summer-ish gray
clouds in the deep blue winter sky it's
been very pleasant day temperature-wise
there so ash on complain we should be
grateful and the other thing I wanted to
point out here because if you will just
pan the camera around sort of been
generally is how fast suddenly all of
the Cambria leaves are changing from
green to yellow to brown
I think it's happened in the last week
suddenly they're switched off blink and
they've assumed their winter colors and
obviously they're all gonna drop off now
leaving the wilderness with a gentle
scent of pot pourri very nice okay
call um I don't have many thoughts on
the Royal Wedding Harry's going bald
like me that's good why I'm probably not
good for him but you have to get over it
his brother's ball its father's ball
dish
it's about interesting there's a screw
it's it's actually quite an interesting
discussion there's nothing to do with
Safari of course but their royal family
I once said to a chap I was staying
darling hotels fugitives drift lodge on
the battlefields of Zulu battlefields
and I said what is the point of the
monarchy I mean it's just a ridiculous
art dated crazy sort of thing I mean how
in the 20th in fact by that stage 21st
century can there be any point to it and
he explained to me that while it might
not have any major leadership role to
play in the country economically the
royal family is worth messes to the
United Kingdom you see how many
thousands of people want to go and see
Buckingham Palace how many millions of
people around the world would have
watched that royal wedding they are on a
giant generator of income for the United
Kingdom which I found fascinating so
they don't just take a whole lot of
taxes and kind of expect to live off the
land they actually seem to make a very
enormous contribution to the UK's
economy alright that's the last thing I
have to say about them let's head on to
the schools now they're having a very
pleasant Sunday afternoon frolic on this
Jekyll berry tree looks like two adults
Pradeep you are very happy to see
squirrels well good I think they're very
sweet and if you can watch them for long
enough they're almost always doing
something interesting that is of the
tree squirrel for those of you don't
know much smaller than the European gray
squirrel and the only squirrel species
that we have in this particular area
couple of squirrels in South Africa
including the ground squirrel which uses
its tail as a parasol Johnny is rather
amazing right squirrels have disappeared
we are going to disappear
Taylor is about to appear well maybe
just a stick and some prints on sand and
we've got some female leopard tracks was
crack cool so here's the pad and here
are the toes so they don't look
particularly fresh but the ones we had
just a moment to cut up on the road are
definitely from this morning and the
James May I showed you towards the end
of the Bush walk as he was coming up
from philemon step so we think it could
possibly be shudra on our way back from
elephant Plains where she's been for the
last to 24 hours the last two days or
three days at least so there's a
possibility we may see it so that's
quite exciting so we're gonna try and
stick on then I'm trying to see where
they're good yeah actually go all the
way along here and that's where her bees
lettuce is actually down this little
mitre drain and well I don't know where
we're gonna go next from yeah I'm
unfamiliar with shoe dude whose roots I
mean every time it runs normally header
it's been a little bit further to the
west and this is going towards ingwe
alley to it back towards twin dance
which we we did see her once
up top here at quarantine and she went
down in a tracks went I think a little
bit more Eastern we interesting to see
what happens and then something that she
really might eat as a scrub here and
well plan today that sort of resembles
the scrub Hayes tale with much
imagination and that's this plant over
here this is called hey tails bush
quite cool it's quite a prickly plant as
well it's not very nice to sort of touch
quite robust I don't think anything
really eats at a console have ever seen
an elephant pull it off the ground and
munch on it now it's not a grass it's
actually I think it might even be a herb
it's a bush though and you can see it's
quite steamy over here you can see how
the leaves are divided but it doesn't
look very nice okay pasta that I've ever
read anything about it being poisonous
no just never really no just any animals
eating it it doesn't also grow in
abundance though you don't see much of
it you just see it popping up every now
and then yeah very prickly okay well
should we catch up with Herbie let's
keep going so we going jump onto this
which kind of turns into an animal
pathway which is quite nice lots of
thorns there lots of debris I think that
was brought in by the tractor though
although the elephants do favour this
area too and lots of creatures do it's
not a particularly great area to walk in
as you can see look how thick it is this
grass is quite tall so we're gonna have
to be quiet as we navigate through this
area
Ralph however is it a much more open
spot and he seems to be up on a rock and
we on very big flat rocks yeah it must
be said this here is called second rock
and this is the perfect SOT I would say
for finding predators in winter I'm sure
they'll come out here and bask in the
Sun with the rocks holding quite a bit
of heat and it's probably the perfect
site for sundowners for guests as well I
would imagine that and the guards that
moon move on this property do come
through here and stop off for sundowners
or a nice coffee break in the morning
but it's a lovely spot to look at as
well and we do see as we start panning
there you will see off in the distance
there's the Drakensberg even starting so
it's a beautiful little satis we haven't
seen too much in the way of animals just
yet but well it's still early in the
afternoon I'm sure
as it starts cooling down a little bit
we'll get to see a little bit more and
then that's when I'm gonna be putting my
concentration a little bit more on to
finding those predators that we love to
see but for the time being I'm just
enjoying being here on Torchwood we're
in the north-central part so not but we
haven't gone too far just yet and just
enjoying it indica girl like that you're
asking about these rocks because it's
probably quite fascinating in terms of
the geological formations yeah and this
is all granite just by looking at it
from here and it would obviously be very
volcanic so you've got a very coarse
sort of minerals within granite and it
does make for quite sandy soils as well
once it breaks down so all along the
edges there and the fringes of this rock
you'll have pioneer grass species
because that's where you've got your
first succession stage starting to
happen as these rocks wither and break
down and then also next to it like there
you'll see plants like the red bush
wallow and also sickle Bush and here's
one of those little butterflies I don't
know if that's a and didn't sit well
enough or so lots of white on it and
didn't see any of the other colors you
do see a lot of the orange took the
whites at this at this moment in time
and it's quite a large butterfly that
but I didn't see it long enough to
identify it but there you can see some
sort of cluster leaves in the background
is some marilla's and then is all the
general trees especially going down into
the ravines you know start to have some
Jacko berries and they pretty much ever
greens one of the only trees that you'll
see dark green at the moment and that
they are some psycho bushes and some
sweet thorns down there and then there
is the trees starting to lose all of the
leaves so very pretty and I think well
the discovery of this new Traverse needs
to continue I'm very excited let's uh
let's hit on art and see what else we
can find very nice I lock the spot and
it's obviously with this with the flat
rocks like this it's a good site for
animals to come and get a drink of water
as well take care I agree with you
thanks for your comments such diverse
vistas and and lovely area for Stephane
predators absolutely total agreement
take care and lots of new space to get
lost in and find little secret nooks and
crannies I love it love new areas it's
like going to the Masai Mara for the
first time now joy from Hong Kong I
think we could be in with a good chance
of us seeing a cheetah
and because of these open areas as I've
heard once before on the radio with the
guys that said this cheetah here on
Torchwood so that since I've been here
so it's not necessary necessarily that
we're going to see them all over the
place but there is a good chance of us
finding some so we'll just keep our eyes
open and these kind of open areas a
perfect habitat for them but you know
they do quite well also in the thickets
but as I say since I've been yeah I
haven't had any cheetah on Juma I never
hear on Torchwood so as my hand
continues for animals
it seems James has beaten me to it
yes we've stressed you to it absolutely
mangled you beyond recognition to the
finding of animals to be fair I knew
they were here that's not really what I
came down here those of you that are
wondering that is a really based a young
one born probably in December this year
not this year we haven't had December
this year that's impossible
December last year putting it as nearly
six months old
yes see turning to agree and really this
herd as I've said to you again and again
this and so well with the disappearance
of the Lions from this area who have
been charged to Craig they're messing to
come towards us that's very nice
normally they're just running away
frightened some reason
and the lights really quite pretty at
the moment it's not soft as it might be
but it's nicely filtered by the clouds
but it's great wonderful
passing the parade we're having hello
chaps
now of course David get you would
consider this a completely ridiculous
thing for us to be doing common as
common as you like in Kenya but here to
have a sighting of wildebeest laughs
this is fantastic
let's count the little ones one two
three four five six
does anybody remember how many there
were
to start with one two three four five
six seven baby
Conrad's is six so I think that they've
all survived all in fact more one two
three four five six six 86
yeah they fared rather better than the
Egyptian Gosling's but you may have gone
from seven to zero rather quickly so
it's sad as if you don't know been
following the fates of Egyptian
Gosling's and one of them died and then
the rest stayed at purfles a quarter
hole for some time there comfortably and
now it all disappeared including their
parents they might be in another water
or somewhere else
absolute panic unique I think that is in
a brilliant description of them he said
they look like cow horses they do look
like cow horses the reason that panic
there was not because Craig waved at
them or said something nasty it's
because there's a warthog that's come
down to a little pan behind this thicket
that we're looking at just behind that
thicket there craigers there is a water
pepper water Pig and we just carry on a
little bit closer and see if the water
Pig isn't confiding enough to let us
look at him there he comes
it's just seen us don't worry and the
male water Pig thinks he's hidden in the
shade doesn't know about the sharp eyes
of Craig
come on then what are you looking for
some you aged just nine years old the
answer to your question is well almost
some of the animals aren't here are very
good at surviving without water the
Steinbach is one such animal
there are desert adapted in many
respects the leopard is another that can
survive almost without water
black-backed jackals do very well in
some dry areas but warthogs and
wildebeest for example are animals that
need to drink very frequently so they
will not do well in any kind of dry or
desert environment now I can tells the
young male of course by the fact that he
has four warts on his face two big ones
next to his eyes two smaller ones behind
his great big canine teeth the ones that
have just erupted from the side of his
mouth he's very nervous of being looked
at and male trying to find his way in
the world the young males trying to find
their way in the world can often be
slightly nervous of being looked at
Craigie you get quite nervous being
looked at don't you mm he does
on the go
he's very crystal clear this afternoon
as I'm sure you saw when Ralph was
showing you the mountains we were going
to try and do the same there was a
telegraph line and wells of power line
also a telegraph line cutting our
picture in half so it gave up on that
telegraph line how old am I not that old
we're going up a Monde or the road now
through the central western regions
Kirsten what was that foul thing you sit
into my ear
they're just basis basically the saying
I am old or dangers middle-aged okay
any idea 42 is middle-aged is Kirsten oh
good what I've got a few months then I'm
still young I'm still a youth
ah 45 to 65 is middle-aged Scotch I'm a
spring chicken I've got another three
years of youth to go
that's fantastic really exciting to be a
youth again when I thought I was
middle-aged a new lease on life do you
ever I sometimes this has got nothing to
do with Safari as well but I can't find
anything Safari right now do you ever
have dreams of going back to high school
and being back in high school I do from
time to time and it's almost like a new
lease on life because you go back to
high school but with the knowledge that
you have as a 40 year old puts you in a
rather advantageous position I feel but
with an extra 20 years all right well
let's go I believe we're going across
not to somebody who's just finished high
school so you are so funny
I'll have you know it's almost been
eight years
oh my no no that's wrong that's right no
that's wrong I finished in 2010 at the
end of the year so I suppose that's
right Oh anyways yes I was in high
school not so long ago that's nice being
young James very nice you enjoy you're
experienced years but we are standing in
a pool of water perhaps James if you
dived into one of these puddles of mud
it might be the Fountain of Youth who
knows you won't know until you give it a
try and you could pop out looking like
you're fresh from high school no I was
hoping to find some evidence of
elephants that have been here perhaps
splashing themselves with mud and then
leaving a very muddy trail that we can
follow but that's not the case at all it
doesn't really look like match has been
in here besides the odd could you
there's been a couple of Impala that
have come down to have a drink but soon
this is not going to be a very nice
place to come and wallow in it's getting
very many very quickly
and I can't imagine too many things are
going to want to have a drink from here
well I don't think elephants would be
drinking from here I think they
just be using it as a mud bath I don't
think a buffalo would mind too much
drinking this one actually didn't Paulo
in fact they just drink whatever is in
front of them some animals are pickier
than others when it comes to fresh water
and no spiders actually I wonder if I
wonder around in the corner if I look
over here where there's a bit of grass I
might find some spiders Pierre the
Buffalo those are always a mystery and
at the moment they seem to be actually I
spoke to a friend of mine and he said
that even they have not been seen
Buffalo and he went he works down at
mala mala and well that's a property
notorious for well just animals all over
of the variety of kinds it's a very very
very beautiful property and he said the
Buffalo been sneaking in and then
literally disappearing straight off of
the traverse back down towards the same
asabi River and whatever other rivers
might be down and around a little bit
further to the south and to the west so
that's quite crazy he says I just pop on
so I don't know they're obviously
hanging around a bit further down there
I'm trying to see if I can see anything
but no spiders normally there's some
creeks water spiders here they're always
catching things but I wonder where
they've gone now perhaps it's a little
bit too cold for them maybe in the shade
anyways that's alright we can carry on
from this little mud wallow but Tim it's
a pretty cool spot I would love to bring
guests here just to take them out of the
vehicle maybe have a little stop a
little stretch of the legs and just to
show them what sort of goes on around a
mud wallow
you know seeing all vegetation around
that that's completely covered in mud
there's probably I mean the leaves
aren't too covered in mud but there's
lots of made going down further so maybe
from an elephant or something standing
here wallowing away or even a buffalo or
a rhino coming past and just scraping
along it as they go out cuz you know
they love to use the bushes for a little
scratch too so that's also a possibility
and then for gonna have to do a bit of
walking my friend because there's
something very cool that I need to show
everybody so I'll meet you here
I'll see you in a minute it was a long
walk a food to freedom Lee JB I would
say yes most of the umpires have
finished their right we're not really
seeing them as aggressive as they were
this morning we watch two postures one
another for a good couple of minutes and
didn't really seem like they were going
to fight at all we're not hearing the
gurgling sounds right through the
evening like we were just a few weeks
ago so I suppose we are at the tail end
now it should be ending shortly but have
a look at this beautiful
what's one what was once a little
vacation tree it's docked at the moment
courtesy ah so look at all the mat on
there so this is the rubbing post this
is the official rubbing post for this
little pan I'd love to know how many
different animals have actually been
here and scraped off of the excess mud
and then it's not just that oh my
goodness if you look inside yeah Wow
what's going on there's a whole lot of
ants you there's some well not huge ends
whoo bees also told me that he can hear
something are they preparing that look
oh one of those el aids so we've
obviously had a bit of rain at the
moment and normally after a bit of rain
the ground is nice and soft and termites
and ants will release el aids look like
cocktail and sexually you know that
there are cocking their tails that may
be one of them and I think that was a
little wind eyelets it could have been a
prince or a princess getting ready to
move on out well start a new life start
a new colony somewhere else that is
really amazing I'm not trying to not get
pricked by thorns I can see hmm doesn't
seem like they're attacking it I mean
they're just helping it guiding it
everybody 'welcome saying well dan good
back on your adventure maybe something
along those lines that's awesome to see
so there we go might as well check on
the termite mounds tonight maybe
something for Ralph
jain's to do a little bit later because
they're typically more releasing just as
the sun has set that sort of first hour
of darkness might get some cool
silhouette shots of them taking off just
gotta find the right termite mound will
hold in the ground for the ends very
cool now why is it who be had actually
your asian thorns sorry what you don't
get stuck on those thorns food yes these
are nasty pieces of work yet who be gave
me the signal he said something was
going ah ah i don't know if it was
baboons although it was a kudu barking
but who bees over there so we're gonna
go that way i think he obviously wants
to go and follow up and hope you pointed
in that direction and funny enough James
has just heard some alarm calls in the
distance well we've been told about
alarm calls in the distance and I was
just thinking to myself well there no
one will believe me when I say this that
if hookah Morey did come on to Juma the
likelihood is that he's gone towards
Galago pan which is just near the camp
just near the final control and so I
thought to myself I think we'll go and
check there well blow me down if I don't
get the radio call saying there are
monkeys alarming and Tagalog out of hand
right now go and have a look so that's
what we're doing
at great speed
it's where David eStore and I ran down
the road this morning on our run we were
going this fast it's probably fast -
even we were going so fast now going up
hands down there but if Google Murray is
coming from this end I think he's going
to pitch up at the we are tailored and
so I'm going to go down that way first
and then we'll approach from that side
Audrey is around looking there as well
there's an Impala looking very relaxed
I'm gonna stop and listen just yet just
get into the area first Andy there are a
lot of Impala looking relaxed from the
damn camera as well which doesn't bode
too well our search let's go and see
for know that this is a bumpy and
another one
Oh unique was a terrible dream you
dreamt last night that Hoku Mori died
I'm sorry about that I hope he didn't
deal dreams normally come true
barb it flying overhead all righty we're
arriving at the booyah Taylor dam now
there's a booby trap in the road here
masquerading as a drainage bump
whoops there it is we've made it a flea
yeah one more
alrighty now we can switch off and
listen
never won I could hear the wind in my
ears
yes very children looking in parlors and
the children yalla
okay I'm gonna stop here and just listen
and we got pans in that way but there
seems to be no more sound coming from
that direction okay let's move quickly
here we go very quickly round that way
I hope I haven't picked the wrong
direction yet
monkeys will not alarm call for anything
unless it's serious so it's leopard or
lion there's some pretty runnin not Anna
panicked manner just sort of jogging
kind of manner not alarming
so there is a lion or a leopard around
here
Halla looking relaxed we'll stop on the
top here
hello kudu have you seen any leopards
hmm I described that response is nothing
short of disdainful let's move on yes
she certainly does have a lot of
oxpeckers on as there's birds with him
Oh
oh he must be careful we don't want to
drive too fast and drive over a whole
lot of tracks
at the same time you don't want to drive
too slowly
mr. two-block I'm afraid I don't know I
haven't checked up recently you say is
this anybody is there any update on
hisana I haven't heard any update on him
I'm afraid last one I had was that he
was on elephant Plains was a long way to
the west of us but that was it I believe
he did have a meeting with the Andersen
male the meeting resulted in probably
his scuttling away as fast as possible
yeah Anderson mayor is not to be trifled
with very large male in the western
sector of the sabi sunt
karate we're into the area now but I
can't hear any monkeys alarm Herbert is
also coming into the area to give a hand
let's quickly go across the tailor and
find out what she's gonna do to help the
cause here we are we are we are we going
to change we've just we just been held
up for a second with some bones some
here this was done very very old done
but unfortunately for us
no actually fortunately for us what am I
talking about it makes it a bit easier
to see what's going on so I need a stick
because I'm not touching that with my
hands let me break a stick off quickly
sorry while you have a look
probably two seconds okay little sticky
there we go so this looks like vertebrae
when we're thinking maybe an Impala or
something like the long those lines is
lots of bits of Bones here and maybe
from a hyena cuz oh well that would be
very very soon I'd be quite surprised to
find so many bones in a lion or leopard
done I mean if it's something really
small like a baby Dacre or Stian book
you'll find the lines and nipples will
crunch right through it or a baby Impala
but that's not the case yeah it needs
some of the shards of bone up and sort
of digested and only really hyenas over
teeth that are powerful enough to crush
through that's a bone like this some of
lions unfortunately don't quite have
that capability mmm delicious but that's
enough food poking for one afternoon
poopy what's the plan that way back
together girl who a B C's we gonna go be
going in that way so we are gonna have
to if we want to help James we're gonna
pick up the pace now so well we will do
we're gonna just me end over here but
once we get onto a road I think we're
going to actually try utilizes the roads
and big animal pathways where possible
depending which is gonna lead us on the
quickest route sometimes the animal
pathways are the quickest but we're not
going to be wading through thickets like
this I don't think we're going to choose
the path of least resistance today well
and I think somebody else is choosing
that pathway today is Ralph I wonder
what other areas is explored on
Torchwood
well exploring is exactly what we're
doing and we just as I said just driving
and up and down every single road we can
come across and yeah we we were a little
bit out of signal for a little while so
just taking another ride aiding back in
a westerly direction just to get us back
in that wavelength where we can
broadcast back to everybody but as I say
for the moment it's a little bit quiet
but I'm not fast it's all exciting and
davia and myself we both enjoying it
yeah just looking at the new terrain and
hoping that something pops out in front
of us but yep we'll wait a little bit
later it seems Jones and Taylor buzz all
over those alarm signals I'm really
hoping that that is shadaloo haven't
seen her for a little while so I hope
that she's decided to show up in here -
Gallagher pan that'll be wonderful
look at this this is like a little bit
of a psychic patch yeah maybe you can
see a lot of these well there's some
young late woods some sickle bushes
there's these silver clasp sleeves and
obviously the red bush willows so when
it's dominated like that with a finger
grass and some of the herringbone - so
it's just one of these little sodic
sites you know you often have a bit of a
place where your water is seeping out
and then it will be evaporating and
leaving a lot of the mineral salts and
then you have a lot of these particular
trees growing in this kind of areas nice
and open but quite devoid of animals for
now just keep searching around as we go
and enjoying the new base
what does the next corner hold for us
what are we gonna find I'm gonna wait
till it's dark and get lost around yeah
that'll be nice and Davi and let my
battery run set so we don't have a map
we'll end up in the Kruger
[Laughter]
that is a joke by the way that's just a
jack cross rides Davi we try right
haha see I love this kind of navigating
who in this some read Gracia to meet a
tree Andra that this is the corner grass
we want to see because this is very
nutritious grass and we'll be finding
animals feeding on that more so than a
lot of the other grasses but it's not
dominating it's just a little bit of
little patches patches of it not quite
unlike in the Masai Mara especially in
the tomorrow triangle it's dominated by
their dread grass and that's why the
elephants and all the animals are are
they fattening themselves up and just
eating grass which is for me fascinating
never seen elephants eating grass like
they do in the Masai Mara and in the
Mora triangle to be specific Wow very
very nice
Philip there's not a particular time
that elephants will necessarily go into
must together they do it it's normally
fortnightly or every three weeks once
they become or get to sexual maturity so
it's sort of once they get around 20
years older side then they will come in
to once sometimes twice a month they
were going to must sir and it will be
different for every single individual
just depending on his age and when he
was born and all of that so yeah and
that that then ensures a nice cycling of
Bulls coming to massed at different
times randomly and that's one of the
things in the bush as well randomness is
one of the most important ecological
factors because nothing is really always
in tune you've just got random things
happening you know like I often think
when I go for a run and the lizards are
running away from me if they run away
from me
they could be appeared to Whiting me and
it's just total random that I was
running there that this Blizzard ran
away and then there was and he ran in a
particular direction away from me and
then something mark now that and you
know things happen randomly which is
actually quite scientifically proven to
be one of the best ecological factors
that keeps the diversity in the bush so
we even studied that in ecology
randomness was one of our real subjects
that we we went through and one of the
real important factors Archer
like for instance way seed lands totally
random it might be blown by the wind it
might be dropped with the baboon having
eaten the fruit and then sitting on a
termite mound it might be carried by a
bird stuck on its Pole and walked off on
a random branch so there is so much
around randomness that you could go on
for days about that a spider throwing
his little web into the wind and way it
randomly gets blown and hooks on a
branch and you know all these little
random
randomness that can turn into patterns
as well it's quite incredible
yar randomness one of the very important
topics that we did discuss and study
it's quite strange to say that you study
randomness well it's very interesting a
so there's a lot of things that do not
happen through sheer random saying that
must be nice to study well it's pretty
random to study I would say but it's
yeah pretty strange that randomness can
be so specific and so make for such
unique biodiversity and it seemed very
important that you do have randomness
then not everything needs to be set by a
pattern and I mean you can have birds
landing randomly with migration they get
blown of course you have random weather
patterns you have you know there's
randomness is basically infinite so yeah
it's like we're the too much swim the a
lights when I got out of the nest and
they just land randomly at a place and
they randomly meet up with another
random female hold o mile you know and
then they they dig in a random spot and
hopefully it's not on the right because
they get squashed by moving through but
you know all these termite mounds they
would have started off by randomly
getting to a little spot that stopped
him from moving any further and that's
where they started and now we've got all
sorts of different randomness that birds
will land on it the boons will go and
feed on it
now cheeky pinky bass I think I've got
that rats are high-power cheeki breeki
bass well
the randomness does keep NYCHA in chick
absolutely I agree with you and that's
why it's such an interesting topic so
yeah please feel free to send in any any
of your random sort of systems that you
see in nature how things happen randomly
that that cause then the diversity or
the uniqueness of nature very very
interesting topic that I mean like the
lipids sometimes they can also just be
randomly walking up a road and then they
you know you've got to Impala that are
fighting and like shadaloo she's
absolutely random in her movements but
with there being so random she comes
across quite a lot of potential food
sources because she's zigzagging she's
going up to him right now she's coming
down she's jumping up the tree she's
playing with her prey you know so that
randomness I think makes her actually
more success successful then if she was
just walking around on a sit root on
every single die doing exactly the same
thing that randomness really mixes it up
and actually puts her in a better
position so it's good to be random I
think is the moral of the story
Kathy I haven't seen any random animals
just yet I did see two random
gray-headed Bush sharks that seem to be
chasing each other quite randomly and
there's a squirrel running up the road
let's see our random he's gonna be
watching they just did up there and I
bet you it's gonna be two seconds and
he's good I love the way they're there
and the check that they leave it's
always it's always one two one two one
two it's very random check it was from a
very end of animal that's rear-ended
when you say Davi I think which way left
okay random chosen let's see here we go
and now straight okay so while we got up
this random road and hope for anything
random to jump out the bush let's see
John over to James and see how random he
is I don't think that I'm very random at
all
randomness in nature is actually a
fascinating concept as it is in
economics for example and it is the
cause of Black Swan events in nature and
in economics we're looking at a red
billed ondol in case you're wondering
and we've had no sign of any track hot
server and when used in the way that
Kirsten has just used it for example
that's so random it is in fact
nonsensical there's nothing random about
that horrible what she means is how
obscure which is different from being
random I think
Kirsten would you like to come back
would you think that I'm right Blanche
I don't think that there were two words
it can be used interchangeably I might
be wrong that he's having a good Sunday
bath everyone should bath at least once
on Sundays so that you fresh for the
week Craig you know I like to bath on
Sundays have my weekly bath on Sunday I
nearly even had a shave today you can
believe it but then there was no hot
water and I decided no that would be so
I can here the only thing I can hear
alarm calling at the moment are some
chin spot bath is's and they're gay but
I'm not sure that that's what they're
calling it 11 Teresa I can do my best
you want to see a yellow build horn Bell
I don't see why we shouldn't be able to
find one for you they're common so we'll
maybe try and find one for you I'm gonna
go up this way because Aubree went down
that way towards the rear Taylor
waterhole where we saw lots of general
game very relaxed so we'll just listen
up for the radio and then just see if we
don't pick something up going up this
road here it's corrective to me but
they're not alarm call for something
else like a number or something yeah
they might they might also alarm for an
aerial predator
like a crowned eagle I suppose they
might from Marshall Eagles Craig
suggested they wouldn't alarm for many
of the smaller things that squirrels and
Franklin's and Mongoose would alarm call
for all right we've got Audrey going
down Central Road Cecilia the best time
to see were words to see birds in this
part of the world
sorry Kirsten I can't hear you the game
drive radios going her going out with
the name lavinda there's time to see
Birds is between November and April
basically all of the birds are backed by
well mid-november and they will stay
here the migratory species and till
around about April and then they'll all
go back up to the north
either intra African or paly Arctic
very angry Franklin's there next to this
or behind this herd of Impala and parlor
looking so there's Franklin's again
really upset but you know they could be
upset at anything just a little
suspicious that it's around this
particular area so the Impala cast their
eyes towards that area that didn't worry
too much about it we can drive down
there it's on the old hyena den Road
[Music]
let's pop down drive a little bit faster
it gets here somewhere it is here and
it's a hyena I'm gonna check out the old
neighborhood
Franklin's still shouting
closeby
I feel like they're close enough to the
Impala that the Impala would have
reacted more angrily if they'd seen a
predator
we see one
just in here the Franklin's
true you can hear that but I can't see
what is making the noise
okay let's carry on because whatever it
is is moving
I can see the empower are still
completely relaxed the other side their
horrific road full of stumps
the old hyena den his last pop past here
no one is at home hasn't been for some
time
no a wild alarm call chase Taylor and
Herbert are coming up here and so that's
the best for a way to find predators
basically on the foot we are James we're
not far actually we're about to pop out
onto Central maybe only 200 meters from
via teller dam so we're almost there
we've been marching we watch out for it
let's take a step to the left lift a
guard enough to guide you anyway so
we're on a big animal pathway as you can
see it's just quite nice this is a very
well worn line I've actually shown it to
you a couple of different times of
scenes and gone and walking down it I've
actually seen Tandi walking down it
Karuna many times with tranquila and
husana and tail and who else lots of big
animals - elephant's like to walk it as
you can imagine it's quite a nicer and
ice perfect because it's open and then
you can have grass or leaves so you can
feed on the tooth you know if you're on
the road you're a bit restricted you
kind of just got grass that's growing
there and then the vegetation starts a
little way off but yeah just listening
as well we can't hear any of those alarm
calls just yet that James has got up
ahead no Bron it's fairly easy to find
your way in reserve but that's also
because I've been based here for almost
two years now and you kind of just get
used to it and you use the Sun to
orientate yourself you use of course
where you can use stars not that we're
walking around at night but if you get a
bit lost in the evening and then of
course as you going about you start to
notice well certain things certain
landmarks big termite mounds mess of a
ruler trees big knob thorns or lid words
that have been pushed on over so you use
those as well
and you just get familiar over time if I
always say the first game reserve you
work on is the hardest to learn and then
it becomes substantially easier a long
way
we didn't find it too hard to navigate
in the morrow is actually quite easy in
fact it was near the escarpment on one
side you had the river on the other said
stay in between and when you wanted to
go home keep the river on your right
keep this government on your left-hand
side and head north you'll eventually
find a road that looks familiar
so that's really the plan well let's
plan when you're starting up was it's
very easy no we're still just trying to
make up some distance before the Sun
Goes Down because it's gonna go down
quickly but we'll hopefully find there
whatever is scaring the birds James how
irresponsible offence did she say live
live yes the game drive rodeos exploded
to life in my ear anyway here we are
with an elephant bull uncle he's just
sort of examining us he just was
wondering kind of aimlessly down towards
us here and then stopped when he heard
us as we did when we saw him only seems
to be recently tossed out of his herd I
guess
see how close he comes I'm just going to
be very quiet he poses no danger to us
we obviously pose no danger to him okay
here we go
so sometimes he's young boo who'll just
pretending and they become relatively
entertained by the presence of a human
being I think you know there's such
social creatures elephants and I think
being pushed out on their own needs and
bones difficult so they'll seek out
companies hiring
that's not gonna make any friends
whatsoever
it really is manners from the bowels of
the bowels I'm just I'm not starting the
engine because I don't want him to feel
like we're a threat I'd rather like him
to just come and say hello to us so it's
a little awkward with the aerial in the
way I'm sorry about that
he's now hiding behind the bush thinks
we can't see him
they are cheeky Jemma you said yeah you
love young bulls because they're so
cheeky they're cheeky but they're also
inquisitive and I think he's being
cheeky
just yet he's just being inquisitive no
don't go away come on stay with us let's
just watch carefully if he is actually
eating this he just sort of pretending a
little bit is cheap tummy
turn up now you see you watch him now
it's gonna turn quickly so you can look
look at his reaction to us as soon as we
started the engine he started to feel
threatened immediately the tail came out
and he took a few steps to get away from
us and eyes turned to face us and
flapped his little trunk over his tusks
so he was immediately threatened by the
starting of the vehicle and that's
normal he's on his own
young bull I wouldn't say he's more than
18 17 18 years old and the confidence
that he felt in the herd that resulted
in his bullying the young youngsters and
eventually getting thrown out by the
matriarch that confidence has evaporated
as he's gone off on his own
sorry Shawn I've got a little bit about
what gets tossed out of heard I missed
the wrist sorry about that
oh do elephant cows I forget tostada not
at puberty but there must be some
splitting of herds because obviously
hers don't just get bigger and bigger
and bigger they they split and in this
area 10 to 15 s about the average size
of a herd in total which means that at
some stage they must split up now
whether that say I don't know what
should we say not physical altercation
but a permanent disagreement if you like
that occurs between two cars in a herd
and one takes perfection off I'm not
sure whether it's just a slightly more
distantly related car moving off on her
own to set up her own herd I think
that's much more likely because it gets
unwieldy moving around in a big herd out
here 10 to 15 seems to be the optimum
number so you know the short answer is
no they don't get tossed - that puberty
like these chaps do but they do split
from time to time
Marty Ralph Kirsten is still knocking
about on tour children I hope and he
he's found some water yeah this is
called lead wood damn well it's live
wood water hole they do dam let wood pan
whatever you want to call it and it's
obviously a number of lead woods around
there is one solitary hippo and there's
also a pair of Egyptian geese sorry for
all your Gosling fans I had done CNE
Gosling's with them so we haven't solved
the mystery just yet unless they
miraculously appear out of the grass
there's also a couple of water sicne
just running around there there's one of
them I think there's another one
somewhere part of a pair there's a
bearded woodpecker hitting on a branch
nearby and so nice little spot for
birding and the Torchwood lodge is just
behind us so this is a view that they've
got from the camp at night with the NASA
spotlight down over this little pen here
and then signs of elephants and I'm sure
you'd have all sorts coming through here
at night lipid - lion - jackals and
Caracol maybe even porcupines all sorts
it's a lovely spot it's very nice very
calm at the moment
take care yeah I'm pretty sure that they
would have called Torchwood
after the ballon artis is probably a lot
I've seen a few I haven't seen sort of
hundreds of them that would suggest that
the place is called debt but yeah we've
just pretty much run a sort of cross
through the Traverse for now and as I
haven't seen too many but yeah sometimes
you know there might be one particular
area that they call this place after
maybe as we go down this drainage run in
front of us is also part of the mall
Meeny which also includes and links back
up on to Juma now I'm gonna continue
down and let's see what else we can find
but it seems James has got my favorite
mammals to show you once again well here
we have some elephants but they're
obviously the herd from which that
youngster is being excluded slowly
they're not very relaxed they've seen
something that's made them feeling upset
made them feel upset not feeling upset
now the big cow to the right-hand side
of your screen there with flapping her
ears that's her she just went like this
she went as she did that the herd
started to move forward the younger cow
that years out is showing not extreme
discomfort but certainly a level of
discomfort that would make me want to
back off if it wasn't for the fact I see
she's not a car at all the young bull
and this big cow at the back is clearly
administering a little bit of discipline
that's what's going on here
I suspect that she is the reason that
young bull was on his own not putting up
with any nonsense that was her cough I
think the little cough is shouting
because she wants milk now Kirsten that
was not me that was the little cough
Destin's directing the show by the way
in case you're wondering I'm talking to
this is lovely
now here comes that's the young bull no
it's not sorry to the lift of there
that's the youngster was standing in the
middle of the road of his ears art
Ashley it is possible but it's very
unlikely no it is a car you know that's
not a young bull is a car just not very
confident one young car of the herd may
be really interesting she's got very
small mammary glands which indicates
either that she hasn't had a baby I
think she's pregnant actually if you
look at the belly she they are she's
quite heavily pregnant but I suppose
perhaps as with human beings elephants
have mammary glands of different sizes
make absolutely no difference to their
efficacy as deliverers of milk was quite
interesting never told it like that um
regarding elephants that have never seen
humans before yes it is possible it's
very very unlikely in the Kruger
National Park it could certainly be
possible in a place like what should I
say in an area like Gorongosa in
Mozambique as possible more remote areas
possibly some of the more remote areas
of Zambia you know you looked quite
large swaths of land that don't have any
people in them that's possible but it's
it's unlikely that in on a continent of
1 billion people at the elephants
haven't somehow somewhere come across a
human being
well they're aged for you learn to get
yourself into trouble by asking this
question because your mother's going to
ask why are you asking it you say do the
elephant's ever hi pretend they're
feeding and when they're not actually
eating no they don't they don't need to
willow because their mothers don't tell
them they have to eat they just get
hungry and eat so although their mothers
will show them what to eat they don't
check how much they eat so they don't
feel like eating theirs don't eat unlike
us when we're little willow like you for
example I'm sure they're lots of things
that your mum and dad tell you to eat
and you don't like to eat them and so
you sort of pretend to eat them and
maybe you feed them quietly to the dog
under the table or slip them into your
pocket don't forget to take them out of
the pocket if you do do that well I
don't know about you but when I was your
age my mother used to make me want make
me eat pears and I couldn't stand eating
pears I still don't like pears because
of it
I remember that very distinctly and
scrambled eggs I used to pretend to eat
my scrambled eggs but we had a very
hungry dog at home she quite like
scrambled eggs didn't even montes very
fat Labrador doesn't look anything like
these elephants this is a young girl
elephant just off to the right hand side
now it's a bit of lighter than there's
other ones hello
yes that's right you on camera no you're
very smart
it's quite interesting let's just get
back here so now that way crepe the way
she's moving that same car was just
giving us the open eared look and stay
with this youngster
so obviously the matriarch of this herd
Brooks no trifling with and so
everyone's a little bit on edge and
she's tossed up that main male that we
saw earlier
she might accept him back if he behaves
she promises not to bully anyone
ESCA I think that what happens is that
they they slowly start to move away from
the herd it's not a kind of cutting of
the ties so they'll spend increasing
amounts of time away from the herd and
then rejoin it again and increasing
distances away from the herd and then
rejoined so they rejoin all the time I
don't think they they probably even join
some herds that are unrelated to them
just for little periods for short
periods until they're really are ready
or feel sufficiently confident to go off
on their own for extended periods pretty
sure these elephants will eventually
fetch up at either the Gallagher
waterhole or the pan at where Taylor Dam
and just be able to hear the tearing of
the grass but I have heard no further
alarm call of any sort whatsoever
now Tandy was seen late after Drive at
the sub dam so that's where we're gonna
head now it's in the far northeast
corner first we will wait for this
rather large cow to come towards us see
what she does
hello my dear you are not small you also
not to be trifled with laughs yeah she
is also pregnant I think she's got much
bigger memory in the glands cheeky geeky
bets in a theory yes that is exactly
what would happen you say what would
happen if a car ran out of milk with the
others help yes they would elephants do
pickup orphans so it's quite possible
that a nursing cow would allow a cow
whose mother was producing insufficient
milk to nurse from her always happened
but yes they are friendly like that they
are familial like that she's telling the
others to get on with it
go on move on
also pretending to eat there oh she said
after maybe an actual bite maybe she
just wanted that tree for herself I
think they've been to water actually
already I don't think that they are
going down towards it you can see
they've got bits of mud on them they've
obviously had their drink throwing their
mud all over themselves and now they're
having this Sunday dinner mm-hmm of
silver trust a leaf how delicious
another leaf Taylor might be quite close
by on the termite man so if she is on
the old hyena den tell her that the
elephants are coming her way would you
oh no they're coming our way as in where
I'm standing right now well then we best
best be be we be quick then so we get
out of the path where the elephants it
looks like there were a few here we
passed some dung now I can hear James
just started up his vehicle seat isn't
too far away from us
so basically we're at this termite mound
that once was a hyena den it's not a
high unit in anymore
and we're not gonna get too close first
year I'll show you why is because if you
look over here there's a track that
track over there is of a warthog and
there are lots and lots of water tracks
going in and out of this this burrow
it's quite a deep one it goes in quite
far back I don't think there's anyone
inside at the moment but let's not take
a chance maybe there's a porcupine or
something but you can see it was clearly
a hyena and in at some point there's a
piece of hide I'm not going to pick it
up I'm not sure what it's from it's also
covered in mud at the moment so it could
be from anything and then there's
obviously part of a skull part of a jaw
which I would imagine is that from maybe
something like an Impala or even a bush
back what are you from
I wonder it's been eaten mm-hmm
punched away bit the little hyena Cubs
that were here may have had fun with
this trying to have a look so what that
could actually be it's not actually a
very big skull too big to be I think
something like a steer book or a daycare
it might just be a young hole it's got
fully developed teeth though I wonder
what it was and so I don't you think
maybe maybe like a bush back or
something well quiet like a female
female Bush back maybe I think the skull
would extend a little bit more but yeah
very interesting
very cool it's nice to know that
somebody else is using this home load
while ie nazar away I've not touched
something that doesn't smell very nice I
don't know what I just touched there's
another buyer actually just over here -
this one doesn't seem to be used as not
sure that that one seems to be active
there's some water hog tracks coming on
around here walking her down and around
doesn't look like there's any hoof
prints going all the way down inside
this one is not as sort of dug art as
the other side very cool though very
nice to see it's actually a really big
trim up man you realize how big it is
until you step out of the car you come
and stand next to it it's massive it's
much bigger than any other termite
mounds I've seen the hyenas living in
very cool no I don't actually just think
that that there's warthogs living here I
think that there's some porcupine looks
like a porcupine was digging in I was
eating some of the roots and you know
what
thank you food that city when you
thought that there was water I mean a
porcupine living here as well know who
was might even vm could yell we all say
it was fake I think Maybin vm saying he
saw some evidence of porcupines around
here this makes sense - so maybe there's
a couple more tunnels - now poor guy the
natural habitat of a wart ogres well
typically a burrow created by an
aardvark or any animal that can do
more dogs can dig fairly well too and
they'll use it out because it's nice and
hard as a bit of a shovel tooth they
need to shovel out some dirt so living
in a burrow of sorts it doesn't have to
just be returned my mind it can be
straight down into the ground - and and
then while they eat grass so anywhere
where there's grassy sort of areas
that's what they typically if you don't
know every now and then double fruit as
well wherever wherever you find those
kinds of things that's where a warthog
will hang around so this is actually
perfect for them nice spot
get the afternoon Sun look at that so
maybe come home a little bit earlier lay
down in the dust enjoy the Sun listen to
the calls of leopards and the night and
hope that hooker more he doesn't come
and find you
he's a specialist wartime hunter that
feller and waits for them must be
terrifying being a water rat we're gonna
keep going I think we got to move away
and art from these elephants now we'll
see what her he has to say let's go to
Ralph and see if he's moved on from laid
wood damn
yep we have moved on a little bit just
we've got lots to explore and discover
so there wasn't too much happening
lately with Dan so we thought we'd just
continue on the exploration of the new
Traverse very pretty area this again
we've been driving along the moon while
nini
drainage line which is a mouthful but at
least yeah we've got a good opportunity
of finding lipids in in these little
drainage lines possibly still lying up
in the shade and also maybe there's some
lions around doing what they do best but
that Sun has started to head towards the
horizon so and it's cooling down quite
quickly as it does at this time of year
as soon as that Sun starts to hit that
lower angle you start to feel the chills
and especially now when you're driving
away from the Sun immediately in the
shade it drops a couple of degrees
immediately so yeah that's that time of
the day now now we need to keep on the
move and see if we can find any
predators that are doing the same but
that was a lovely waterhole that led
with damn I'm gonna be back there go and
check that area out as well as those
rocky areas especially in winter I think
are gonna hold some animals on a nice
cold winter's morning with the Sun
coming up I can just see those lines
lying on those rocks be perfect perfect
so and we also saw a lot of euphorbias
euphorbia candelabra candelabra however
you pronounce that and like those big
chandeliers that you get with the top of
and with those type of candles on the
end apparently Kerstin telling me that
James show do the other day
those euphorbias a little bit behind me
I'm just keeping on the move because I
just want to see if we can find any
animals moving around I can hear some
Koki Franklin's calling funny Franklin's
those are very small ones actually when
you first see them you're much mistaken
them for like a grass now my little map
which way we going we'll take this main
road left yeah I want to get onto a road
that's called lion track I've got a
feeling there might be some Lions on
lion track but Oh got ya just in front
of us is it a female spotted wood dove
now we D in Washington I hope that I can
show you some lions because you're
saying that you'd love to see some well
I'm gonna hit for lion track I think
that's probably the best spot to spot
Lions and look at this little emerald
spotted would does doing what they do
based foraging along the road generally
doing it into the Sun you see so my
little tracking theory is a brilliant
way to work out and the time of day that
this animal was walking because they
normally walk into the Sun and so if
you've got a emerald spotted would dove
that walked over a check you need to
look if he was going east or west if he
was going east then it's normally that
he walked over it in the morning if he
was going west then he would have been
walking over it in the afternoon so
you've got a little bit of a timeline
there if you look at him or spotted
would have tracks and if they're going
over on top or if they're underneath
lipid track or lime check and then you
know using that as as a nice way to
judge
in the check that you're looking at to
trying to work out when that animal
moved through there with regards to the
little emerald spotted wood dove and
I've got a lovely call a very food hoot
and the the zulus and sangan's they said
that it's a very sad bird that call
especially because he's saying that his
sister sick his brothers in jail his
father's a drunk his mother died lost
German I'm so sad said said said he said
story coming from the emerald spotted
wood does shine but yeah I like to just
think of him as a as a very good
tracking assistant so it seems everybody
is looking for birds and finding them
let's head off to James and see what
beautiful bird he has I've got a
beautiful virtual Starling that it is
sitting on a tree sure I did that right
mm-hmm yes and it's just sitting there
not doing anything except warming in the
Sun possibly eating the odds is it was
fruit you can find one there's some on
the tree then we are now before the
quarter hole where the world's most
boring hippopotamus are living and there
is no sign of the Egyptian geese and the
Gosling's I'm afraid and nor was there
any sign of Fundy or Columba it's quite
devastating that these egyptian gooses
have disappeared but it's entirely
possible
given the distance they walked to get to
the Ruhr teller waterhole that they've
just gone somewhere else that they
weren't heading back here at all and
they headed off in this direction
they've gone to find another waterhole
summer us
well done Craig let me just go forward a
little bit
liquid could pop out here at any stage
Oh
our alarm or I think very effectively
one is taken back to that classic Disney
movie of the 80s called the incredible
journey where I said two dogs and a cat
or two cats and a dog or something make
their way over Hill and Dale to get home
no it's not homeward bound Kristen it
was made before you were born anyway I
think they find the instinct for finding
home or exceptional and my evidence for
that is Cinderella the young male
leopard who was shadows son he went into
rehab for rabies for six months came
back we don't know exactly where he was
released for some unknown reason there's
a whole fail of secrecy over that anyway
he was released back into this area and
made his way straight back into his
mother's territory so he knew exactly
where he was after her six-month absence
so I don't think it takes him very long
to learn an area at all and whether or
not they're actually picking landmarks
or just feeling familiar or picking up
smells or whether they have some kind of
ability to navigate like birds do using
the Earth's magnetic field some birds
are able to do that I don't know but I
think their ability to know exactly
where they're I was exceptional alright
not much going on here so let's continue
homeward bound
[Music]
indeed
we did see some of what ralph is just
about to show you now
[Music]
real symbiosis in action because the
I've stopped Yun is a couple of horn
balls around with these little dwarf
monkeys and the monkeys are not really
relaxing with our presence are now he's
shooting sight into the Sun so now he's
got to try and ask me with his settings
they may be overexposed but look now all
the little dwarf mongooses are starting
to get relaxed and still quite nervous
that we here they can hear me talking as
well very close to them who the ones
even standing up well of course as I
said that you went down it was a real
good look at us like a surrogate very
cute mumbles were just throw out there
they're not quite as young one a little
baby the smaller one anyway looks like
it could be a baby oh that one's got a
little weight patch on its back or it's
missing some here one of the two what's
happened to you Betty you get you get a
trust cool maybe a rap show or something
got old of him and he managed to get
away
hmm quite a big wound on its back at one
stage if it was and we end would I think
it was the clock it was a beige see how
close they are to us with the vehicle
right next to them and I'm making a
circle noises
yes look at this there's all sorts
happening with these little guys
coming out all over the place and
Kirsten says is a bit of action just
nearby to me I'm actually on my way to a
sighting but it's one of those animals
that probably not going to be moving too
far so I will be on my way there shortly
but we'll just enjoy these these little
Mongoose for a little while here hey I
love watching monkeys the place today
family also one of the ones that do sort
of anal markings anal gland
so they mark their territories there
must be some kind of little resource
yeah don't know if it's insects around
as I said the horn balls were yeah also
feeding all right I think it's time to
start up and head on down let's go see
if we can find there's some animals just
up the road yeah not far from us I'm
gonna see if I can catch up with him all
right so I'm gonna listen out on the
radio and find out exactly what's going
on but I'm sure there's all sorts going
on with the bush walk team let's head
over to them and see how the game we
just standing in the golden light
perfect just doing this waiting
patiently and we waited patiently now
have a look at this I almost I basically
almost died this often I'm just trying I
didn't almost die but I almost fell into
a very big hole now what we've got over
here is quite interested it's an
intricate system of burrows beneath the
earth but unfortunately it's all
collapsed you can see look how the sand
has just fallen down over the entrance
of that tunnel and I don't know if there
were maybe porcupines or a family of
warthogs living here cause it's an
extensive area and then this is what can
get you into a lot of trouble with the
vehicles is when you have off-roading
here and you can't see it because of the
tall grass
you will go straight down and probably
get the vehicle quite stuck now this is
epic
my colleague Ron is just sunk straight
down into the middle now you wouldn't
want to fall in there and the rest of it
is all hollow underneath and it's
amazing it's a huge tunnel network and I
don't even think we can begin to guess
how far these tunnels go in and how how
much space is actually underground here
but a perfect spot for warthogs for
porcupine even an aardvark iene --is
tortoises well not down in here now
Steve you said while I kind of wish I
had a big powerful torch kind of like
the ones we have on the on the vehicles
that I could shine on down in here and
just see exactly how deep it actually is
but I thought that was quite amazing
we're lucky that we found this because
now when we do come off-roading in here
which is an area we try and navigate I
know we're not to drive we're not to
bring a vehicle anyway because I even
think if we extend to where I'm walking
now I think even up to about here we
could be in a little bit of trouble and
luckily for us none of us are heavy
enough to make the earth collapse I mean
it's probably about that thick but a
vehicle that weighs well over a ton
probably be in a bit of trouble
fantastic what it Herbie gonna this way
oh is this that I heard him whistle
shall we go that way so we haven't
picked up any signs whatsoever of a
predator obviously that's what we've
come to walk in this area here the
elephants getting closer and closer so
we're going in the opposite direction
and this is where the alarm calls were
coming from we were chatting about
whether there that monkeys that were
alarming though exhibit monkeys could
have seen a predator all this way and I
think it depends on which tree they were
sitting on but I do think that it is
possible but this is a fairly sandy
animal pathway that we're now on and I
think that we would be able to see some
tracks especially if they were fresh I
don't think would be too much of a
problem someone was running here however
maybe an Impala just dashing across this
pathway
hmm now Paco who is only five years old
I'm trying to think of what alarm calls
I think are quite scary mm-hmm and you
think of any when you hear a kudu and it
does its big bark standing right next to
you but you don't know that the kudu is
there because it's hiding away and they
feed you while camouflage
that's scary do you know what just gave
us a really big fright now we're some
birds can you believe it the Franklin's
they're probably the most terrifying
they're only scary when you're on foot
because you're walking walking and they
panic and they've seen you and all they
go do we pretend that we're not you and
just sit quietly in the grass and then
they go okay okay right everybody we're
going to pretend we're not yet we're
gonna hide from the humans and then last
minute one goes I can't do it I'm too
scared and then flies but it's right at
your feet and then you jump back Herbie
and food to the leap of about two metres
backwards I also got afraid I was
blinded by the Sun so I was like oh I
don't know what's gonna get me anyways
but they give you a fright
jackals don't have a very nice alarm
call it sounds like somebody's screaming
which is not very nice when they when
they are shouting or howling into the
night hmm who else what about a baboon
when the baboon goes job ah I don't say
that but that's what I have to say to
make in a baboon son Ralph actually
there's a very good Baloo Baloo not a
balloon and a dune alarm call we'll have
to ask Ralph Paco can ask Ralph to make
a boon alarm call for you I'm sure he'll
be obliging Casey who's directing this
oh sure she says a human yes we don't
have a very nice one and we normally use
colorful words when we get scared hey
food right down into the drainage line
we go this is a lovely area it's really
is quite nice for walking and only going
to get better and better in winter it's
very very pretty now it seems as though
just as we are taking the path less
traveled today so is James I wonder
where he's on to
we've just checked the brown ivory tree
which in Ghana had his kill and exactly
a week ago I think he whacked that in
parlor and stuck it in the tree when it
was raining and it's not there which
means that some of these taken it out of
the tree perhaps a bird drafted or tündi
wind up and scavenged it but we do have
some information that Tandy's tracks are
going south down drakensberg road which
is not too far from here just in the far
ways east east east I've also had a
lovely message from Kirsten MacKinnon
Smith that says apparently project alpha
you confirmed that the incredible
journey was also known as homeward bound
so we were both correct she then sent me
a rude sign with a picture of project
alphas tweet and there was a rude sign
with it that I can't share with you this
is what we put up with on Drive you know
trying to concentrate trying to do the
best we can and we get abuse from the
final control just to be useful so I'm
sure to you to the shops
the lady could have seen such a thing
terrific
hey there's little water all up here on
the Drakensberg road as I've done there
and see if we do not get lucky there's a
yellow belt humble who wanted to see a
yellow behold oh there it is there it is
quickly Craig that's going to fly away
and have a birthday Teresa there you are
are you not pleased Teresa
how could you not be especially it's a
very confiding one book it seemed to be
particularly worried eating it's not a
chameleon is it it's a little cat I did
know it's a mantis you're absolutely
correct or don't rate a mantis poor
Mantis crushing the wings they're
crushing the chitin in the wings and the
exoskeleton that's what this is it's all
about because obviously there's no
chewing finding teeth in hornbills bills
like finding hen's teeth and down the
hatch it goes swallow hope it's not
wriggling and jiggling and jiggling
inside her well done Teresa
epic yellow-billed hornbill sighting
their marvelous
let's continue room if ever you are
wondering about the road names here and
you want to know where we are or how and
eventually I imagine that we will be
able to give you an actual live feed of
where we are but the the Google Maps map
of Jummah has all the road names on it
and so if you ever wondering if I say
I'm on drakensberg Road you can actually
go look and see exactly where we're
driving torchwood not yet it's got the
roads but there's never numbers the
names
Janson this is a unique feature of this
wonderful vehicle known as the Land
Rover Defender the wheel turns so much
because what is known as the steering
box I don't know what that is it's a box
that is not something to do the steering
inside is well shall we say
temperamental to say the best so you can
see that when I do this the car hardly
moves but if I Drive in a straight line
what you'll notice is that the car will
suddenly start turning one direction
there we go in our going off to the lift
so it does its own thing and that's why
it looks like we're moving all over the
place the actual fact that a straight
line is driven with the steering wheel
at that angle there I don't really
understand
don't know sorry about that
yes there are ton DS tracks that's not
done these checks at the mail
the male leopard going down this road as
well
they found a young male leopard just
down here I'm on my way where's my game
Drive radio I'm on my way just down here
the Mayo at the end of these tracks hold
on Craig don't go anywhere I'm going to
finally give you something to film
big bump turn up the game drive radio
four-wheel drift source about fun
now ever the young male leopard would
possibly be the magical Hashanah back
from the West would it be tomba back
from the southeast
it's the next road junction is where he
should be
nearly there everybody stay with me now
I can't hear you sorry cuz I'm going to
turn you down so I can hear ovary bulbs
go again
it's horse hot now
the one minute from Junction Bethulia
haha that's very exciting there is is
this marvelous was a stroke of luck
and you see him this one next one now oh
there is on the ground either eating
something or his own foot that's
wonderful thank solves there he is
everybody he's back home in Ghana it's
not what's on that sting gone everybody
it's all right little dude matter slight
anticlimax but it's still nice to have
him I thought those tracks were a little
bit large meself hello hello now we had
those male leopard tracks
you know what Herbert said lost
yesterday he said he thought those cat
was around here somewhere and his teeth
are in fantastic shape for a deputy of
his age nothing wrong with his
composition he's obviously paid a great
deal of attention to keeping them clean
so it good dentist work done
hello boy
[Music]
he means businesses caetna he's looking
in superb nick muscled and absolutely
fine down the road just it all read get
out of the way by getting out his wife
now what we'll do is we'll alternate as
we go down the road everyone so you'll
go in front the nar will go in front
then he'll go in front carry on orbs
calling in forms
you get past
in common world food
but magic
he's just sniffing some elephant dung
there I'm not sure why somebody's always
he marked there I suspect handy she was
around here earlier I'm thinking of
trying to get around the front of him
okay while we do that
Ralph Kirsten has managed to find his
first big tortured cat well everyone
here these female lions they just um
started walking towards us through the
block I'm not sure which group which
pride these lions are from I'm thinking
that it's maybe the inclement but I have
no idea just yet we've just seen some
lions that's all I know so we'll just
wait and see once we can get them a
little bit closer
they will my ball towards us now I've
just gone down so I'm just waiting a
little while before I go rushing in
there and then they walk back up towards
us where we are anyway so that's why I'm
just staying stationary for the minute
we just let them do their thing as they
were on the move and we saw three of
them I'm pretty sure there are some more
moving through the bushes but there's
one that we can see and it's funny they
walked and then they just slide down all
of a sudden but I are still awake and
looking like the might get up again so
it's just why it's a little bit and if
they don't move then obviously I will go
in a bit closer and get a bit of you I
just want to wait and see what they get
up to you for the time being
so yes the first
hands-on Torchwood I looking around
maybe we will even get a hunter you
knows it's the perfect time of day
there's still lots of light and it's
getting nice and cool and then Arsenal
it looks like Tyson flies there a little
bit this female in particular she looks
like she's got quite well rounded is
there no real Nick's or cuts in them to
talk of good-looking female that
perfectly camouflaged in the long grass
looking south towards us giraffe Cole
asking if it could be the Torchwood
pride I'm sure it could be giraffe go
we'll have to wait and see and get a
little bit closer on the on the
identification sir
absolutely it could be the Torchwood
pride or the in coomer's what easily be
the Torchwood pride yes I don't think
I've seen him before
so we'll be nice to see them wonderful
new place new pride of lions possibly a
locket look there's another one just
underneath that silver clasp the reef
are we on the left that's where that one
went down there she's just picked her
head up yes
and oh this by running out is some
running towards him let's come in here
we are and I can hear some contact
calling going one as well awesome looks
like a young male sub-adult yeah they
come perfect and I wasn't even trying to
be panty a so the contact I wonder
what's been going on and look like
they're waking up off to their days
sleep lots of yawning a little bit of
energy and it is all sorts of little
contact calls going on oh this sounds
like there's more coming
okay I think I'm just going to get it a
little bit closer in here Davi this is a
bit frustrating if we're not really
seeing much being a little bit far let's
get it clear of you shift
you can see them nicely this all sorts
the other come running in okay so how
many get in yeah a little bit closer and
we'll get a perfect view but let's send
you off to James it seems that in
Garner's on the move two feet from where
I'm sitting you're magical he's just
depositing some popcorn okay
very obstinacy deposit he may
cool
we're just gonna let all we get past I
did a whole special Bundy bash to try
and get around in front of him and then
he lay down in the road
alrighty the Lions are else Gordon are
on the move so let's go back to him as
that one is just disappeared behind the
bushes but we've got lots of stuff
happening in front yeah this is awesome
there's a couple of little sub-adults
the Cubs yeah so I don't think that this
is that uncle MERS I think it must then
be the torch with pride and they look
rather skinny so that would be well
worth watching because I think they
could be a hunter on the card see how
this evening might only happen much
later but our definitely hungry cats
and there's all sorts I haven't counted
that meaning there was one that just
came past us now and there's two three
four five six seven eight nine there's
at least ten eleven
that's not twelve thirteen so definitely
not doing kokoomus to bigger prior than
that there's lots of them around here or
thoughts happening well minimu that's a
very good question why don't males
develop a dewlap
it seems that it seems like it lipids
are pretty much the only ones that
really pick up that out of the cat's the
males obviously oh that one right next
to that car
this is sharpening his nails as the
males and lions I've got that big mine
and you wouldn't really be able to see
it even if they did get a dewlap so
potentially when the old males get older
and into their later years that
potentially would or could have a dewlap
but we don't even see it but it does
seem to be reasonably unique to the
leopards I haven't seen it on any other
cats never seen it on any of the females
are there and having I do get a bit
older they can get a bit of loose skin
and so on ah so everyone agreeing that
this is the Torchwood part thanks guys
for helping us I was pretty sure that
with these numbers that definitely not
them come as needing to Torchwood pride
as that one was just having a little bit
of a sharpening session there's a couple
of vehicles in the area here
as three vehicles here now that's the
max that we would have lower guests also
enjoying the sighting as well perfect
timing this law is just becoming active
now couple of youngsters around so
there'll be fun and games but if
tackling in chasing each other around
and that's I say we've all positioned in
different spots yeah the one and has
come up and lie down in a bush just next
to us but we can't see her and so I'm
not gonna move just yet just wait a
little bit and see what happens - I'll
try get as a nurse for you well okay
well we'll wait and see what happens
with these lions but James got ting gone
are walking down the road he's still
coming we've just got into beautiful
position we're now on our own with him
he's being serious about his calling
he's walking along here making a big
noise that netted ear speaking of a
potential fight at some stage of his
life
I wonder if Tandy is not around here
somewhere
and that's not what he's smelling Vicki
this is a very subjective thing to
answer I think King Ghana is heavier no
it was slightly taller but the same sort
of thickness as Hope amore
how Kumari to me is is not a large
Leavitt is a small Leopard and I think
well I mean relatively and I reckon that
ting Ghana is about an average-sized
male he's a good size but he's not as
big as the Anderson male and he's
slightly bigger than in bulla was and
the average male mass in this area he is
63 kilograms so about 130 pounds hundred
and forty pounds aim is on the front of
him
sorry about that Bush sorry boy he's got
up because of me I'm sorry about that
also got up because there's so much Bush
that I can't turn around turn the game
drive ready up okay we're gonna keep up
with him let's go back to the lines here
we go everyone it seems the Lions
haven't moved too much so we've still
got a very good view that is a very
pretty female there but as I said
they're looking quite skinny and every
potential that we might get lucky and
watching them do a bit of hunting and
quite nice so on Torchwood that it is
reasonably open although in this
particular area that we're in is a
little bit of a drainage line that the
Lions have come out of so what thick
down there but as we move away then it
becomes a bit more open so could see
them a little bit easier than in some
parts where it's very thick
especially on Zoomer and there's all
sorts of little contact calls going on
with him down there
little minds and groans and out
see can tell the females will also mark
territory yes they they will also be
moving around and on the patrols they do
spray on all the bushes next to the road
and any prominent features and each one
piles past end guys and sprays so yes
they will also be marking that
particular area of days out was lots of
spraying and a group of this it's quite
a sort of a traditional or like a
routine and I walk around the particular
territory and then each one was walk
past and have to spray on a bush that
they've designated as the spraying bush
and then they move on again and then you
know any of the little prominent
features and one of the females keep
sneezing and just off from us yeah and
not that one yeah and that one's looking
movement here okay I think I'm on right
now so I'm gonna just reverse it's like
they're playing on the right that's what
we wanna see
come on Sasha rugby skills good tackles
and wrestling match here we go games on
guys making each other youngsters
and there's a little bit of cooling as
well
that's gonna happen next
it's awesome when you've got a big pride
of lions like this and there's all sorts
going on there's some more making their
way towards the road with these two are
there one looks like it's got a big
growth behind the back of its league did
you see that Darby just before it went
down they had headlock on its elbow a
real big ballet key on the back there
okay I'm gonna see if we just can get a
bit of view here um but let's hit you on
to the bushwalk team I wonder how
they're going it's getting quite dark
now I've never scaled the tree so
quickly in my life but food looked at me
and said you wanna climb a tree and I
mean okay I don't say no to a challenge
should be up in the tree hey it's not
very stable though it's an old tree I
think it's an old Hobie what do you
think this is an opto on it old knobs on
yeah it's looking at the bark good view
from up yet though really good view you
can actually start seeing down and sort
of through the trees now and she'll
it'll open pockets of grass which helps
a lot sorry oh this is the second time I
don't know if I can know I don't like go
once Sebastian made me holding the moon
but that was a sustaining on the car and
it was flat so I don't think I'll be
doing that remember we did that in the
merace
that's quite cool I was living Fergus
pointing and I was like what do you see
you [ __ ] oh that big thing I say I'm
probably gonna come down now I think I
think this is what we're gonna do oh my
goodness oh don't no one jinx me don't
say anything because he's just said my
tumble how will you feel Kirsten if I
read how bad will you feel if I really
hurt myself now yeah make the guilt sit
in
yeah easy peasy that wasn't so bad
this is James's tree by the way I've
stolen it from him he normally likes to
climb it at the back of the tent and
we've been creeping closer to home
because that herd of elephants were
moving on in and are starting to get
dark right now
apparently there's a somebody else
Archer who's better climbing down and up
trees I suppose that's ten Ghana I'm not
sure what that meant but we still with
10 Ghana he's making wheelies on lots of
bushes the popcorn sent all around us is
fantastic and it smells a little bit
like being at the Bioscope go ahead I'm
just on the game drive radio
yeah probably is going into the
Muromachi now at Beth Lia very strong
smell of popcorn there did you get that
those of you wondering what are we
talking about it is of course the fact
that leopards urine smells like popcorn
satisfaction I have not witnessed a
leopard fight I have witnessed many
leopard standoffs but I have not got any
I've never seen a fight between two male
with ease
it's so rare negative you will not
interfere you do see it from time to
time it has happened
but it is not they will try and avoid it
try and settle their differences with
growling and negotiation before war
takes place you can imagine the damage
the two lepers with that kind of
strength and speed could do to each
other I can't really get round the front
of him over here I probably could
neutralize sorry Ferguson dumped you in
the dwelling there am I supposed to just
touch the key lightly so the cameraman
knows to zoom much rather than just
firing it up
this little cough before he starts I was
a seldom-seen a leopard calling this
frequently
he's very clearly in the mood to Reese
take himself Sam you aged nine they saw
like this to say to announce their
presence to mark territory for the same
reason that he's urinating on the side
of the road he's trying to announce to
any other leopards that this is his
place and that nobody else must be in
his way so that's why he's calling and
he does it by basically doing what I was
doing but his voice box instead of being
fixed in his neck at Gretel's and moves
up and down and that's how he's able to
make such a noise hmm chefs I'm sorry
we're gonna have to destroy patience
with him on the road there's far too
much bush in here sorry about that
unbelievable tea bomb has made it home
to my one of my favorite locations on
this reserve next to the tent we're
still around you we've been puttering
around having a look for things but it's
been fairly quiet as I think all the
warthogs have decided to go to sleep the
butterflies have settled in for the
evening
and while I've already heard part of the
evening chorus by the birds so hmm in
true fashion of course as the Sun starts
to go down in the afternoon we can't
stay out on foot as all the tables turn
and we might get eaten although we
probably wouldn't be able to see where
we were going firstly and as we were
walking with big torches and that
wouldn't be a particularly fun
experience so we won't be doing anything
like that we will probably be retiring
to the DRC which isn't far away it's the
tree literally just behind us goodness
gracious
anyways it's been a fun afternoon not
much aren't they in terms of little
insects and things that are too quick
for us this afternoon but they should be
frozen again tomorrow morning so for
myself Ferg and her tea we hope you have
a wonderful evening
and while the bushwalk team will see you
bright and early tomorrow
we just got browned him so he's going to
come wandering past us now and then we
will see the rear-end often gonna once
again just listening to see if he can
hear any other leopards calling perhaps
he'd like to see his daughter amber with
dribbling that normally means old can
often mean that he's since the presence
of another male it is kind of preparing
for standoff
I think they're due Jensen
I think they appreciate the road a lot
because especially this time of the year
when the grass is so long it's difficult
for them to see and they obviously don't
like getting wet in the mornings
especially in the cold mornings so in
much the same way as they'll use
elephant and hippo paths to move so
they'll use the roads that we produce
I'm just going to gently ease down the
road
it's getting cooler now I think his
sound will travel even further in the
cooler air yeah I know bit of Gua
remarking sorry bull River I missed your
question okay
aim he's got that is truly impressive
yes bulla rave they do saw as well
females that's how they mark their
territories some people will tell you
that they can tell the difference
between male and female roaring or
sawing I can't tell the trees on the
banks are leaving mother while Marty
River
really I mean the popcorn smell is quite
overpowering sometimes he will urinate
on a bush like that on that gory bush
because nothing will eat it maybe not
that I've heard I mean obviously my ears
and anything like as sharp as his but I
haven't heard any response to his
calling but this will be gathering
attention I mean he's being serious
about this this is not perfunctory this
is a real announcement I don't know if
Haku Mori has been this far towards the
east don't think he has
it's a water buck watching him he's
paying no heed to the water buck what
server now the monkeys are calling those
monkeys have seen him from a good I'd
say eighty to a hundred meters in the
fading light
he doesn't care there he is doing his
thing in the bush there
this is classic leopard marking by
rubbing his scent all over that bush
[Music]
yeah they're not that far away they're
about 40 meters away in the tops of the
trees we won't show you them to you
simply because I want to stay with him
and I want to lose them we'll lose him I
suppose we could have a quick look Craig
is let's have a quick look over there in
the lid would fluffy Aussie Cohen
beautiful name you have there unlike the
well in fact what similarly to most
mammal species actually age does not
affect their fertility too much so they
will be able to produce offspring until
the day they die in theory so could most
human beings for example they don't go
through a period of infertility
obviously you get slightly less fertile
as you get older but it doesn't that
doesn't apply to the lepers they will be
fertile until the day that they die
interestingly though when he when we
last watched him mating with Corolla to
produce husana and Shuang Gila I'm gonna
have to drive around the other side
everyone he and Corolla took six at
least six matings before she fell
pregnant and produced from ela and
Posada
Dahm it goes just gonna quickly to say
where he is no not gonna work
stations to ganon our mobile North up
towards the junction of vultures nest
and the other Road south where are you
now come down into the drainage and then
come up towards no good sir just helping
someone else get into the siting he
asked me which way he should come but I
didn't know where he was so I couldn't
tell him oh no this is going to get
tricky
definitely Judea knows doesn't tell him
that tell them that he wants to mate who
tells females that he's around
Judy if you've ever watched leopards
mate it's the females that find the
males and then they harass them
basically until they mate with them but
they do not go seeking mating
opportunities normally the males
you're just gonna let this other fellow
in alright Ralph has left Torchwood and
scared that and find where he's going to
adventure not well everyone
unfortunately we did have to leave that
group of lions because you know there
are some rules that I'm sure James
explained to you the other day but they
were quite a lot of people interested in
coming to see those lions so luckily we
did have a nice view on them and while
we did have to make our exit because of
that so I'm sure we're going to be able
to go in there again but there was just
lots of interest because of those
particular lions there so unfortunately
we had to leave but fortunately we were
allowed to go in there in the first
place so we'll take that one we'll stick
it in the bank and we'll go back again I
think maybe even tomorrow or the next
day
but for now we're back at twin dams and
I'm going to just pop pop one O's in the
air and see what's hanging around have a
quick squeeze if anything then we'll
head up to treehouse dam see what's up
that way and as you saw I'm getting it's
getting rather chilly at this time of
year and this time of the evening
especially when you drive with a little
bit of air flying through pretty evening
was there there's a lot in the
reflections that's very pretty it's like
a mole pond beautiful light I can hear
little pod owlet calling behind us you
do
and there's all sorts of just the last
little bits of the day birds calling or
Franklin and Speer file having their
last little say before the night really
is upon us beautiful that reflection of
the trees there as well that is
spectacular
I'm sure we're gonna start hearing the
whooping of the hyenas quite soon what a
perfect way to in the day that kind of
light nothing in the way of animals
really but it's just a stunning scenery
and a perfect shot all right perfect
that's brilliant camera works here let's
head on a little bit further see if we
can
fun oh right you want me to find some
more bush babies now I think last night
was probably my Bush baby for the year
with that way that it's a set lock that
perfectly but I'm definitely gonna try
again I just up from us here as we janet
is it Gina
Jackson Janet Janet Jackson hangs out so
maybe let's have a look baby I don't
know if it's a male or female I've just
seen the little straps of them of the
Janet in the hollow tree
I'll have a look there and see if that
if he's if he's active he or she not
quite sure if it's male or female
then I'll go and drive all those little
roads around tree house damn these
savages track and shabam ooh and those
little roads which is what are we yeah
on the southern boundary and there's a
nice little roads they are absent in
Ghana they before I've also seen no
sauna and other time is is worth ting
gone and now but and the Oklahoma's were
here as well the other day when I caught
up with him on foot that song kuma lion
pride and the elephant caucus is just
off to our sort of north waist now yeah
anything's possible in this area right
it seems like ting Ghana's got himself
quite thirsty so let's go off to him he
certainly has and he'll probably drink
for quite some time now
leopards although as I've said before
independent of water largely
they do very much enjoy a drink especial
Sunday evening inhale for a hard week of
sawing and making a noise he keeps
hearing something keeps hearing bits and
pieces moving around hurts an editor oh
it's a thing we can't speak about -
coming towards the waterhole sorry I
became overexcited he's gonna move off
you can see we have chat a little bit
earlier about that ability to orientate
themselves and you can see he knows this
area completely perfectly you know
exactly where the water is there is a
little bit more marking and he will now
probably follow this game part it's my
favorite game part goes all the way up
to that little pan where I started
yesterday's Safari live show I'm not
sure he were watching or not and then
you probably fetch up at where Taylor
dam Ralph cheetah Plains come in
Ralph is also seeking popcorn but of a
different kind
Ralph is on the everyone I've come here
to this little house of Janet Jackson
and when we arrived I was looking in
this bottom hall there and there were
two individuals so now going up a little
bit further I can just see the little
spots over there but they've obviously
just got a little bit of a fright with
the with the sound of the vehicle so I
just want to sit for a little bit they
can hear me talking now so I don't know
if they're gonna sell themselves I can
see the spots from this angle I don't
know if you'll be able to from that
angle mmm you can see a bit of movement
you could see the tail going up so this
tree is totally Hollow and they've moved
up in the tree I think probably into
about that area now but very safe inside
there I would say but at the moment
getting a really good visual on them so
I have to maybe just wait a little bit
we'll see if they pop their heads art
otherwise we'll leave them be and we'll
move along because it is about time for
them to start coming out and I don't
want to stop them because we're just
sitting here at the front door and not
allowing them heart to see if they're
show us the hits I won't have to be a
little bit quiet for a while and then
I'll have to calm down it's a little bit
like the Mongoose when you go quiet and
then they start to relax with your
presence and come out but this
degenerates are quite shy so I wouldn't
be surprised if they don't show
themselves while we here
it might be that they are a little bit
camera shy I could still make out a
little bit of a movement in the top all
day and there are up inside you're not
gonna show us all right shame I think
we're gonna leave them a little bit to
char for us we'll have to come back
again we'll have to a bit you ate them
to the vehicle and let them know that
we're not going to hurt them and if we
come here every evening or you know come
here regularly
they might relax what's the presence of
the vehicle if they know that we're not
going to didn't better for now they're
too nervous so we'll move along so from
one little cat-like species not quite a
cat these guys are part of the
Mustelidae and the piece today that's
sort of mixed now but let's go to
another cat with spots
and there he is still marking along I
thought he'd go into some thicker bush
I'm just gonna give Ralph the
opportunity to go past him this is
another elf who's working with cheetah
planes very own brain because we've had
him in front I'm not sure how they're
looking at him but they're being very
very gracious by not spotlighting him
well we've got our infrared light on I
mean it's almost pitch black out here
now
so we won't get a great view from the
little while they get us the spotlight W
James his offspring we tend to think so
much of the females offspring have they
survived to adulthood
well Hasan has got pretty close Tambor's
got pretty close they both sort of I
mean well Silas two and a half just
about he's gonna stop here and Humber is
about to I'm trying to think who else
there was I don't know you know I wonder
certainly none of Tong DS had not Tony's
shadows Cubs made it that he sired who
else would he have sired cubs with he
could have side cubs with some of the
leopards in Buffalo but it's very
difficult to know what's going on there
it was a really good question Cindy Leah
possibly he was shadows one cub that may
have made it to adulthood dispersed as I
said earlier he went into rehab for
rabies and he could have survived to
adulthood he might still be alive
somewhere just have him dispersed
somewhere else I I hate to think that
there weren't any and we don't know all
of his offspring of course because
females will come out of their
territories to mate with males I'm sorry
we don't have it here everybody we will
eventually there's just a very thick
bush here and so it's very hard for
Ralph to get out of the way
all righty we'll keep following let's go
back across to Ralph who doesn't have a
large Cruiser in front of him
well and we are just also looking for
any little not Tom cutters I'm trying to
see if I can find a chameleon
cama cama cama cama cama comedian or a
bush baby or a Jeanette or a civet or
what tailed monkeys or porcupine or even
loose-cannon Leopard
why not Ryan that's a good question
thanks for asking that now not quite
sure but I think the most amazing thing
about my job is like I was talking about
earlier the randomness because you can
come out and drive every single day and
you never know what you're gonna see
like you know I think that is the best
thing about my job
the total randomness of it I know I'm
gonna be driving a vehicle well I'm
gonna be walking in the bush but I never
know what the bush is gonna throw at me
so I think I would say that's the best
part
random total randomness as we were
talking about it earlier and I like to
mix it up so and that just keeps the
work exciting because you never know
what you're gonna get old forests come
saying hey box of chocolates what you're
gonna get next and exactly like what
we're doing now what are we gonna find
is it gonna be an elephant that has
attacked as Rana or a black-backed
jackal that's um fighting with the
servant we don't have to have everything
fighting maybe we'll have a Impala that
has made friends with the water bug Oh
Kirsten says a honey badger giving birth
that would be a good one what about an
owl digging up a
dung beetle nest that would be random
what about a bat that's eating a baboon
spider that would be cool
what else there's a water hole just yeah
we're hitting now down towards treehouse
dam but there's nothing down by this
little pan over here I've just come past
we have found the young coomer's the
other morning on foot no sign of them
mean as of yet I heard that they moved
down onto era Souza oh there was a
random-ass that ran across the road and
speaking of running on the ride it seems
Kangana is back on his he is as is we
had a nice view anyway he'll move into
an open area shortly
no no Kirsten I'm afraid you can't just
discussing her kisses timing has been
then well from the top draw as far as
the sightings gone what I should have
done was actually lift and I should have
just left him in front until we wanted
to link
anyway he's gonna get out of this vast
forest around us eventually and then
we'll both be able to look at him so
Center any questions you have about in
Ghana and we'll do our level best to
answer them
has anybody come up with an answer as to
whether he has a known offspring of
adult age or independence
I would feel dreadfully sad if he didn't
sky I don't absolutely I don't know that
is ting Ghana didn't mate with somebody
before I showed up on Juma he must have
he would have been a nine year old male
I just don't know who and I don't know
what the progeny were none of the
youngsters that were around when I was
here though were his because we were
largely of course with Fuller's
youngsters and I suppose the interesting
part about that is that his territory
definitely shifted as and Voula his
power waned and say he could easily have
I wonder if he didn't matron Kearney ne
perhaps in the East native in fact
remember he used to he must have mated
with he could have mated with Sally she
you know to produce tianni I'm sure
everyone reckons the Anderson male is T
Arnie's for a father but you know he
used to go all the way on to the
elephant Plains boundary which is way
west of here and that would encompass
shadows territory he'd encompassed
salacious territory she was a famous
leopard from some Bambi Lee and her
latest independent offspring is tianni
who's just been mating with the hokum or
email she could easily have made it if
he could have made it with quat Elia who
is since deceased
she had three Cubs that died with her
death and I don't know what happened
after that before that I mean there
could easily be something that we just
don't know
as a young female who comes onto chitwa
chitwa called civ we would be his it's
hard to believe that a grizzled fellow
like this who has done so much to get to
this time of his life has not got one
independent or swim see if we can't get
a decent shot at him
Rhian diga Chava is in fact Fuller's
offspring not ting ganas we're pretty
sure in fact a wonderful Chavo wasn't in
bullies last offspring Paula we do need
a lipid flow chart and in fact we're
getting close to having one on our
website eventually we will have one but
if you go to the website it does tell
you who's female is who belongs to who
pretty much not in a chart but it does
tell you who belongs to bet on the road
here we can try and get around them
eventually a little bit of a road coming
up and I try and get past him okay the
reason we can't see him is that Craig
can't put the infrared light on my of
the back of my head because you'll be
completely blinded by the globe and it's
got nothing to do with any deficiency in
my head rather the power the infrared
light so it's either me or the animal
and what we don't like to do is have the
picture jumping up and down which is
what happens if he zooms in too much on
the animal
okay I think we're gonna have to give
these other chaps a turn that's a nice
picture of him and so in the meantime
let's go across to random Ralphie yep
random Ralph it's better than record
Ralph I'd say yeah we still haven't
found anything too random just yet lots
of little Mossy's and butterflies
butterflies really I think I'm also
moths flying up we've seen the odd scrub
here in a present scrub here which could
like I say a lot of these predators that
are struggling whether they're being
chased by other males or anything else
geesh if I was a lion that was being
chased by other lions I'll just have my
little snacks of scrub here's keep
myself sustained but well that's me and
I can think like a human
and it's not as easy if you're being
hounded by other miles and so I don't
think it's going to be as easy as that
I'm just thinking back to that to that
lion that was spotted here the other day
that was pretty random we're in a herd
of elephants yeah I'm just gonna turn
these Lots off okay we're just gonna go
to infrared because elephants do not
lock lights there we are
sorry about that cars I've got a just as
much as a frat as you did here we are
right in a group of these elephants yeah
and I don't mean any harm and I'm sure
you don't either there we are
carry on your feeding as there are you
can hear them feeding after that
wonderful so you speak of randomness and
it comes to find you very pretty
elephants yeah I can only hear them and
watch them on the screen in the infrared
because in the darkness yeah I can't see
them at all it's lovely to watch them on
the infrared because in this kind of
situation with guests per se I would
probably not stay here at all because I
won't put the torch on them they really
don't like it and they can get quite
agitated what's your putting a torch on
them and well in the dark I don't quite
know what they're up to you so it is
actually ideal and very special if we
get to sit watching elephants in
infrared because not your average guest
won't get to see this in the dark so we
actually get to see them outside of
normal game watching times it's
fascinating
now lien thanks for saying that
yeah I feel that is pretty awesome these
elephants are all around us everybody
very relaxed they're carrying on their
feeding and I love elephants it's one of
my favorite things in the world either
to be doing is just to be in the
presence of elephants it's such a
calming feeling just being around them
yes sometimes they can have different
moods and it can be a little bit edgy
sometimes but on the whole it's pretty
much like this did this one having a
little sniff at us I think also not the
greatest night vision okay so we've had
a lovely little sighting with these
elephants in the dark but I think let's
leave them alone for now and send you to
the nocturnal animal which is ting gonna
turn Ghana has found what Ralph has
found he's lying down and it's so funny
to watch his reaction is reacting very
much like we would he's done stopped
dead in the road and looked interested
but also the same as asked on our way
back for breakfast for example when we
think we're almost home
and then we're blocked by elephants he's
kind of looks disappointed he was
standing there looking from side to side
thinking how can I possibly get around
them without them seeing me because I
will take great displeasure at having
him walking in the middle of the herd
now he's gonna try we've got one minute
left everybody it's keep going I suspect
I support fellow behind us is going to
need a bit of a chance in front I'm
gonna have to let him try you go round
this way
don't also want to go running into the
elephants alright yeah everyone I think
that's going to be probably the last we
see of young Tinky's there is in front
of us we have one last look as he
disappears into the darkness thank you
very much for joining us on the Sunday
sunset Safari we will of course see you
tomorrow at 6:30 huge thanks for your
contributions your questions and
comments are fail I don't say that quite
enough so thank you very much for those
we will see you tomorrow morning until
then bye-bye
[Music]